look at this line
and now look at these three lines
can you tell which of them matches that
first line and how sure are you
hold that thought and listen to this
story because most people can get this
wrong
[Music]
once upon a time on the eve of a major
religious holiday a seven-year-old boy
was observing his grandmother as she
poured an extra glass of wine
when the boy asked who the glass was for
she said that it was for the prophet
the boy didn't believe her so his uncle
told him to just observe the glass
closely
full of expectation the boy watched the
glass intently and suddenly he thought
he saw the level of wine drop just a bit
1951 decades after the incident our boy
became a pioneer in social psychology
determined to rationalize what actually
happened that fateful night
did some of the wine really disappear or
was he made to believe that
to find out the truth he devised an
experiment to investigate whether peer
pressure can be strong enough to change
our perception and make us believe in
things that are not true
solomon ash's conformity experiment was
conducted with 123 white male college
students who were told to be part of a
study in visual judgment
each student was introduced to a group
of six to eight other students who were
in fact actors who already knew what the
experiment was about
the group was then gathered in a
classroom and shown two cards the first
with one line the second with three
lines on it
each student was then asked to say aloud
which line in the second card matched
that first one the group was seated in
such a way that allowed the actors to
respond first leaving the real
participant to respond last
for the first two rounds the fake
students also known as confederates gave
the correct answer and the innocent
student known as the subject said
whatever he thought to be true
in the third round the actors began to
respond with a clearly wrong answer
for the next 12 rounds dubbed the
critical trials all the confederates
would give the obviously wrong answer
so the innocent student could either
ignore the majority or ignore the truth
so what did the experiment tell the
researchers
upon completing 18 rounds with all 123
subjects the experiment came to the
following conclusion
23 percent of the students always gave
the right answer
72 percent conformed to the majority at
least once
and five percent completely succumbed to
peer pressure and always gave the
obviously wrong answer
ash's work also showed that if just one
other acting student responded correctly
the effect of peer pressure decreased
substantially
the experiment also showed that the
opinions of three peers are enough to
influence a student to change his mind
increasing the number beyond three
confederates did not increase the levels
of conformity among others
or put differently if three people say
something obviously wrong and there is
no one to disagree with them many of us
agree with the wrong answer and start
lying due to our deeply human desire to
fit in
since then ash's experiment has been
successfully replicated many times and
the effect remained significant
especially among women and homogenous
peer groups
in 1955 ash famously said the tendency
to conformity in our society is so
strong that reasonably intelligent and
well-meaning young people are willing to
call white black
this is a matter of concern it raises
questions about our ways of education
and about the values that guide our
conduct
what do you think would you have
conformed or stuck to the truth
do you see the ash's effect in your
daily life or in social media and what
can we as adults or educators do to give
young people today the strength to stand
up and speak the truth
share your thoughts in the comments
below
[Music]
this and all other sprouts videos are
licensed under creative commons that
means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do
to learn how it works and download this
video without ads or background music
check out our website or read the
description below
if you want to support our mission and
help change education visit our patreon
that's patreon.com
sprouts